this is going to be things that are
beyond our control everything happens
when it's supposed to happen everything
in this universe happens by law and it's
easy to make a buck very hard to make a
difference I think there's this one
aspect that we all need to accept and
come to terms with in life there's going
to be things that are beyond our control
let's not fight this back and let's not
come into the mode of controller ship
thinking that everything's in my hands
that thinking that everything's in my
hands can disappoint us frustrate us
when things don't go our way so I think
that's one aspect that I talked about is
come to terms with it that there's going
to be things that don't don't go my way
and everything doesn't go by my watch
life has its watch higher powers have
their watch and things will come to us
also you know this this bulbs right up
here you know the lighting of the whole
studio of every shooting it's quite
amazing
this bulbs giving their light but
there's many bulbs in the storeroom who
are waiting there to come in the studio
and give their light so that the
shooting can happen when will that bulb
in the studio ever get a chance to come
up here now the beauty of life is that
the bulb up here doesn't last forever
no bulb is lasted forever and no bulb
will last forever
no speaker has lasted for him no speaker
will last forever no actor has lasted
forever in terms of their fame no actor
will last forever no athlete no sports
person has lasted forever and no sports
person will last
just like this bulb everyone has their
time
everyone has their day and that day
doesn't last for everyone so which
basically means the bulb here won't be
there one day and the bulb in the
storeroom is going to get its chance to
come to this lampshade one day to light
of the studio you know what the question
in the mind of that little bulb bear is
I agree sir all this philosophy
understood sounds good all this gone yes
sounds great all this God sounds great
but how do I continue until I think the
parameter the principle be the value the
epoch that actually helps us continue
with perseverance and patience is hope
hope is that one element that can keep
us going the worst thing to happen in
life is to lose hope and be hopeless so
if you're sitting there waiting for our
turn to come up against hope one day I
will also have my time and my place when
how we do not know because these are
factors that are completely beyond our
control
we hear patience is a virtue I suppose
it probably is but I think patience real
patience is an expression of deep
understanding to see everything happens
when it's supposed to happen everything
in this universe happens by law we set
targets and we need things to happen we
need something to come or someone to do
something and frequently we get
frustrated because it isn't happening
when we think it should happen our
problem is we're not thinking we believe
we're in charge we are not in charge we
are in charge of building the idea and
holding the idea everything else happens
automatically
all ideas have a gestation or an
incubation period I'm told when we plant
a carrot in the area of the world that I
live it takes approximately seven days
for that carrot to grow and manifest in
form when the seed for the babies
planted it takes approximately 280 days
and we're usually patient we will wait
the 280 days why because we know it's
going to take approximately 280 days
well just because we don't know how long
it's going to take doesn't mean that it
isn't operating by the same laws
everything operates by law so if we cane
and understanding that all the ideas in
our mind will ultimately move into form
that's what Andrew Carnegie taught
Napoleon Hill Carnegie was Hill's mentor
he said any idea that's held in the mind
that's emphasized that's either feared
or revered the beginning wants to close
itself in the most convenient and
appropriate form available you might
want to listen to that two or three
times burning into your mind getting an
understanding of it and you will know
that whatever you're working on takes a
period of time no one knows what the
gestation period is for an idea
we only know we can shorten it through
concentration through focus
and when you understand that will become
more patient and when you're more
patient and living in a much more
beautiful vibration you'll be a more
pleasant person to be around you will
enjoy yourself patients it's the result
of understanding raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
we believe that people with passion and
not one drop of myself work depends on
your it's suppose to mean
[Music]
isn't it amazing how many plans we make
and isn't it a reality not everything
goes according to our plans